you
this is a 3o time control tournament
fifty-five minutes of let's just see
what we get here
no increment let's play fast following
not yet a game from the classical let's
stop b5 its solace B thank you for the
10,000 bits man look at you wow thank
you very much
jeez thank you for that appreciate your
support man that's a big donation ok
well let so they're giving me the
bishops I just saw that as a you know
flight square and why not ask the bishop
at least one question I wasn't going to
necessarily follow up with this prepare
route to d1 I'm expecting this move not
afraid of that
just want to get some more development
in let's put the rook here and stay here
I don't want to give up this pawn maybe
they go up on hunting let's just cover
it I'm prepared to play here let's do it
now I want to see the Queen a little bit
more directly now I'm prepared for this
not quite okay let's go here it's an
issue there I'm prepared to start I'm
thinking about an attack here efore e5
let's get on with it
Bishop is here take what the pawn and
[Music]
once it the Queen see what she does
first let's do this now they're going to
defend h7 with Knight d7 fa let's get
this in I want the night to go somewhere
other than f8 so I could go here and
then I want some kind of a rook lift
queen takes a rook takes B
my bishop can also help defend this pawn
if I need it
ah let's go here kind of discourage
these pawns from moving let's control
the night h4 h5 hmm let's go here I
might want to anchor the bishop on b7 if
he ever mows yeah I think that this
would be a really good square for my
bishop did not expect that positions now
opening up likely to my benefit could
take the night Queen e4 feels like I
should have something better though
queen g4 right now Queen h5 takes takes
here King f7 seems to guard everything
I'm playing only with my queen in that
position I'm still going to take it
though this night getting into d5 was
scaring me so I'm going to do this
so maybe the Queen may be the king I
feel like the king would be best
umm my bishop needs to play he's stupid
on e1 at this point
Queen on d5 is probably strong I don't
think I have anything here okay I think
the Queen again would have been better
here gonna go after my pawn yeah he's
important enough well Queen hear ideas
No
okay this is winning me some material
ooh
well is it that a slick move Wow
slick oh my goodness why didn't I move
just then her threatening discoveries
my Queens unprotected no no no no no I'd
be a great way to lose
oh man
they only have five seconds oh man it's
going to be a time when but wow that
would that move stunned me so much
Queen they're setting up a rook
discovery against my unprotected queen
in the center
hmmm that's always a game that those
type of games are always ones that I
want to just go back into right away and
see how I could have improved
okay Elwood got the first one in there
let's try 94
in c5
and let's be aggressive let's get the
bishop here right away and I'm going to
look to start putting some very fast
pressure on the dark squares
who
um is this a move I'm threatening
appositional there's a positional threat
here to take Queen takes and then I take
with this open this file and what White
has to take away from the center okay
now this is just flat-out losing because
I take here and now there's a pin
this wins the farm this wins a full rock
take it now I'm up two pieces
let's take something more now my night
can escape you know this fell apart fast
let's just make sure he's rescued they
resigned back to term
as a very odd game a few sharp moves
thrown in there and Queen b6 to g6 don't
see that too often okay still a lot of
time left there are 59 players in this
one let's try an e4 game have a
caro-kann on board let's try Knight c3 I
guess this is the two Knights CARICOM
daba let's see if they give me the
bishop pair first okay LightSquared
bishop let's see if I could put into use
right away threatening mate with this or
this let's play d4 cancel out the night
[Music]
I'm going to go Bishop here I may want
to play with my C pawn that's why I'm
going Bishop d3 I think I'm this square
there's just too much control over d5 so
I'm going to go here it points still at
what is likely the King position like a
likely Castle kingside and I'll go I'll
go with the Queen so this I can move the
Queen and still defend the pawn
where do I go though I guess here
two bishops neither side has a lead
development wise pretty even kingside
castle or what I really want to go Queen
side I could consider queenside castle I
have to find a square for my bishop
though where is best I'm expecting some
tempo against my queen expecting her
position to be challenged I could pin
the knight right away I'm going to play
it more reserved though hmm let's go
Kings side mm-hmm now I think I want to
free up my Queens role of defending
deform the knight could move with an
attack against my queen but if black is
castled you really don't have that many
discovered attacks against my queen
anymore
h7
converging on each seven well this runs
into Bishop f4 Bishop d6 let's go here
first
asking for some trouble here to be
careful of the forward night moves
they're going that way well Bishop feels
like he should go somewhere else
I may be coming under some fire here I'm
okay if they exchange bishops one minute
left
we are opposite sides castling so I have
to they might start launching some ponds
at me I think this is best to allowed to
allow the bishop to stay cutting into
the position like that
I have bishop h2 and then my queen could
start to act as a bat the leader in this
battery let's uh let's go here preparing
to get on this diagonal the same time my
queen is ready to be trapped she doesn't
have any squares now okay I guess she's
gonna have to be content with g3
so likely be a time when two unprotected
pieces
my opponents play
far better than the writing far better
took up 7e six is now week let's go
after that right now let's attack the
night and attack again strapped nice
strapped back to chairman okay
played well but took a lot of time to
make the moves it's pretty quiet
position alrighty let's see what we get
here English three nights so far
alright let's try for oxy binds and
night see - are they going to take my
night ok clamping down on d5 now let's
follow through with Bishop e2 Bishop e3
this before this so there's no Knight g4
f3 rook c1 ok this is a whole I'm going
to focus on this square one day could
control that and think about hopping
into this square I want a light square
Bishop exchange and then some piece
right here let's put a rook here for
starters let's guard f3
this structure does a good job of
controlling these three minor pieces if
he can't move he can't move and right
now he's biting on a rock b3 let's just
go b3 without too much thought
so Queen to d2 and then the knight
jumping in here Knight d4 Knight d4 into
c6 Bishop b5 into c6 once he captures
like this what's that move about that's
not working this Knights unprotected but
there's that's just not working
Knight takes here I could take like this
no I don't believe it
could also do this move or just Queen to
d2
let's go Queen to d2 covers f4 they're
really just starting to lash out here
pawn takes then they take here I'll take
the phone this is the only thing I see
but that that can't work okay now just
chase me back there let's offer a bishop
no no Queen here if I do this there's
Bishop takes pawn
what about f4 Queen H Queen h4 is a bit
annoying I want some trades spending
time let's stop Queen h4 and I'm like
implying this I'm really asking to get
made it here I'm really asking for
trouble this is really bad when I'm
doing here
these Knights are out of play okay Queen
they're ok this is a different story now
just want some trades I'll take that I
want to give this check and then get my
Queen here to challenge this Queen clean
exchange offer it
you
and kind of watch out for night h3 out
of any fancy Forks opposite this but I'm
keying in on this square Queen g3 simple
enough and now let's just step up
34 seconds
probably an unnecessary move what I just
did there
I'm Knight f5 let's jump in get rid of
this Knight keep this file away and
let's open this up
offer a queen exchange close to forest
Queen h3 I could continue pushing Nike
kyun on f6 about even on the clock now
Bishop is a good block hater in this
case let's improve the King if I did
that right away rookie 4 could have
grabbed that pawn should be able to pre
move this out soon where is the mate
we're almost there
that's me
okay I don't like how I did that I was
up a piece there my nights on the
queenside
or away from the action at some weak
squares F some dark square weaknesses on
the Kings side I thought instead of
Queen f6 Bishop e5 and I'd have to find
some defensive moves which there should
be some defense there but it gets a
little bit scary
35 minutes left in this one camel clutch
errs in first try Sicilian guess II
six-night there may be d5 let's go D 5c
what white does
where will he go some more time to get
on the longest diagonal or Bishop e2
that's awkward
where is he headed some time wasted
let's Fein cut out is he doing this to
free up the F pawn let's go here have
this night here I have to defend d5 now
let's castle prepare e Queen side
fianchetto
preparing B for it's very odd moves it
feels like I feel like the rook has some
potential here hmm I go here there's
shakes I'll still go here to be careful
about capturing with the pawn because of
this move okay let's let's get this rook
here they can't shut it down I have
enough coverage over this so maybe I'm
prepared to take care well I don't want
to help that night out I'd much rather
see him move before I capture here okay
so even like right now yeah let's do it
now let's unleash these two so this rook
is a bit hmm I guess in the end the rook
on c8 isn't going to have a great role I
could consider c4 or even Knight to e5
looking for some direct play I have a
lead in development there's still okay
then you get that they didn't grab that
pawn back but I'm winning this pawn I
have a lot of stuff on it I wanted to
move this night anyway
just as we saw in the one puzzle
position to unmask a couple other pieces
let's take with the Queen because now
that I'm up material I want to welcome
some more piece exchanges which would be
better the rook or the Bishop I'm going
to go with the bishop pins down the
Queen side Bishop moves there's a cost
cannot connected with that
let's take and improve my night to f5
not here I don't want to obstruct this
truck any further
moving forward I could look at rook c2
that was maybe better
rook c2 definitely converging on b2 + f2
now g4 just invites me forward rook
takes pawn
there's rook takes Bishop but I have
Bishop takes pawn that Knights annoying
I think he may be kicking me away from
the seventh second but let's go here I'm
preparing to take the pawn and take the
rook just like in Game one in this
tournament my queen was unprotected on
e4
ok that's clever preparing to take with
the night ok let's just come back all
the way and reorganize here this player
has already shown to be a pretty quick
you're asking for some Forks now knight
on f3
I'm also controlling this a flight
square so back rank issues can take with
my knight let's just back up on the
knight hand upon where's the back rank
mate this is a super strong piece I
don't want to be too quick to just go in
here he might be best well that's me
be best right here simply controlling
that flight square and he was 21 16 16
less than 30 left 76 players now in this
one
let's see we get next some different
early night moves in that game a lot of
time was wasted let's try a b3 game and
maybe I get to push the night away
grab some space open up the bishops eyes
will they prevent this yes let's start
with Knight f3 or maybe we go for a
double fiend cut oh let's go a Knight f3
[Music]
okay let's let's go with the double
fiend cut Oh be looking at these moves
soon let me just get some standard stuff
in stuff my opponent knows I'm going to
do first castle these more committal
moves I like to hold off on although I
don't know how committal that is I
wouldn't be going c3 so they strengthen
my center just then two to two to one in
the center I can push one of these two
we can open up his eyes at any moment
this night is canceled out really well
bought my pawn structure alone he's not
playing where does he belong one of
these two most likely let's go here I
like the idea of playing into b5 at some
point this is a strong piece
this is a weak square in my camp
start with this covers upon maybe
supports c5 at some stage I could have
done this maybe that was best and more
to the point I kind of want to take
advantage of that Bishop being
unprotected let's try for it I'm
threatening c5 now the bishop doesn't
have any squares and if takes I get the
bishop they stop that
but now the physician is opening up in
their queen I think we'll struggle some
let's get this rook working I have a
slight lead and development this night
is out of play
I like this structure which my bishop
it's very solid over here on pawn takes
I could connect with the night of the
rook I think I want to take with the
rook
ok now I'm taking material with an
attack against the Queen and now I keep
a believe forward and look at these
intersection squares d6 this is
collapsing now I could probably jump in
here is there better good spread and
mate let's throw that in there for some
pawn move Knight here defends ok so they
have a weakness here and so now let's
jump into this square or a knight here
right away now let's jump in I'm going
to take with the pawn have a passed pawn
Oh totally missed
all right now we open the night up okay
they resign
yeah they miss that I was on c3 c8
excuse me clearly 23 20 we haven't been
paired up yet
seeing a game he's in a game he's doing
some berserk and still 25 minutes to go
right behind me 18
okay pluie Oh on board I guess let's try
g6
you never know what to expect with these
these ratings still pretty fresh for
this time control
I'm going to try for some positional
line trying to key in on some employing
a dark square strategy with this line
night here and then I'm looking at night
see six first this and if d5 isn't
played I have a quick track into d4
they're stopping that now I'm going to
look to camp out on c5 Knight a6
they could force me to invest my bishop
for night I don't want to take this
voluntarily
let's get developed let's keep this pin
of course don't take unless provoked
and that's I think a problem because
night here hits the bishop and if I'm
not mistaken
I could take this night right now or
[Music]
let's see if they bite
take care this is a pawn sack on the
queenside in order to damage the
kingside structure this queen is a bit
overloaded so they really want to take
here they're going to have to damage the
structure my DS to come out here here
fight for the dark-squared weaknesses
a bad idea at least in blitz
I'd like to maybe get in here I tried
doing it like this but this pawn was
there in time but there are other
avenues in 2d form say they're biting so
let's take here first force this capture
and I don't want to take here because
what I want to do I want to play against
their Bishop so if I take here there's
Bishop takes and then the bishop could
take this Knight out and I wouldn't have
enough material so I think I need to run
it like this I may be damaging my
structure okay now now I'll take here
run away still trying to play against
this the extra pound they have is this
guy but he's a long way off I think at
least from causing me any harm so let's
still carry through with this idea I'm
not quite here to get this exchange in
though am I here but I still think I go
here
we'd open up my bishop sighs if I take
at the pond and I think I am going to
take at the pond yes let me it's an
opposite color bishop bending
I'm also on f2 my bishop is going to be
a monster on this square I'm also on the
rook and they missed that so this is now
collapsing taking up to next I'm hitting
everything
hitting the bishop there's no time for
any sacrifices here even though the
Queen is cutting in this is a fine
structure they just had a blind spot to
my bishop oh you know what maybe they
were thinking my queen was going to take
on f4 I don't know let's take this pawn
and put the rook in the pin I'm also
preparing to take on the a3 now
or just go here and give some material
back and they resigned back to
tournament
is definitely interesting I thought at
least it was worth upon to go in for
that 24 I have fire so this next one
will be a big one especially if no we're
not going to get paired up he's still
berserk
okay
let's try this line again
now this and one the games already in
this tournament ended quick that
maneuver
let's try c5 in that in that game it was
Bishop to h4 so on f3 I'm prepared to go
Queen a5 let's get this check in here
only after c3 well I drop back with my
knight
now here there's this there's this
all right
none of the above let's pull it upon in
the center I feel like I'm better now
because this is awkward this was an
attempt to shut things down but now
let's get a night out not afraid of this
I could come back home maybe I should
have been consider I could come back
home no feels awkward if the position
opens up and this pawn is on f3 in the
night can't go to is most natural square
feels like it's an issue
I'm also prepared to maybe strike with
e5 three pawns in the center open up the
bishops eyes rapid development will be
key let's do it I could get that in and
now an additional benefit is if the
capture then I gotta go with the Queen
Bishop takes there would have been a
fork but you know now I have a 2 to 2 to
0 or 2 to 1 in the center let's back up
throw a punch at the pawn and pave the
way for Bishop c5 I think this is a good
reply still going to go here I want to
maintain my structure this is a tall
pawn let's just kill this square feels
like the bishops close to trapped and he
is you saw this kind of tactic in one of
the puzzles we did just before oh no he
isn't cut he isn't I had a blind spot
there he has a square okay well maybe
this is still good though I could key in
on the d3 square yeah this is probably
still good but in his calculation there
clearly and I give this Square up but I
should be winning upon now now
oh I could jump in can't be captured
because of a fork if I go here he has to
go here
you
you know what I'm going to do I'm going
to go here I want to control D for this
is the the only way this is the only
square White has to work with so I want
double pawns in fact on this capture I'm
going to insert this check first then
take with the pond and then have this
pond come up like that so now I just get
to win upon and I think my night is
going to be the more invasive piece so
let's take the night both of these these
squares are very good pressure on the
bishop I'm defending here so let's
improve my knight got two pieces
covering I'm not allowing this still
can't Castle yeah that's the other thing
now that this Knight is defended
defending the bishop there's can't
complete castling or I can't get the
rook involved can't get the King save
they just dropped that and it's a fork
and be up a rook soon and upon
no time let's take the rook and just get
castled on here I could take the knight
first I'll take here keep it really
simple up a rope go after a pond I'll
just save him now I could take here
threatening mate threatening mate in a
few that's going to do it back to
tournament we got 28 still with fire 15
and change remaining 85 players of this
one how many more games at least to
okay okay this is the guy that's in
second so this is a huge game huge
alrighty
let's block with the night III fish
would be two castles and maybe black has
to worry about a three and B for me
grabbing some queenside space let's see
okay
who
let's get queenside development in stop
e5
lene see - yeah Queen c2 and rook
I guess we'll put this both rooks here I
want to go with this rook firsts
maybe that's not necessary let's get my
queen here first not 100% sure why maybe
I want to go for B for a 3 B form let's
insert this be a little bit more
cautious about this if the knight was on
c6
again with b4 let's go Bishop d3 I might
want to go for some exchanges yeah I
don't know how purposefully III was
I may be threatening some stuff no takes
and then takes here and try to damage
their structure with the LightSquared
Bishop six changed my knight on f3 can
rely on his post a lot easier you can
only be challenged by a knight and a
pawn on e4 a black pawn getting to e4
slight time edge
I can use a flight square we could both
use a flight square still a way forward
is B for just putting some more pressure
on c5 see if he flinches invites my a
pawn towards the center or my e pawn so
now I should take like this first and
then I think I could do something fancy
like this and on Bishop takes Bishop go
here first I think this is an important
structural change or at least one that I
want to get in yeah because now I could
try to play against this pawn I still
have this Knight under control by my
knight and pawn flight squared time I'm
going to go two squares can't take
advantage of g4 and I'm threatening h5
h6
okay so there are sidestepping that
maybe now we go here stop Knight f5 and
do so with an attack against the Queen
so a move I did not consider okay let's
get home a how to harm's way and
threatening h6
so much for that okay I could defend him
let's do it here invites the Queen
forward rook here Knight b5 okay that
weakens d5 let's move forward and throw
a punch
okay I could take here and why not look
here I come back with an attack and
right here I defend a three and just one
upon I'm also up on time
pawn takes I take with the rook and
challenge the Queen pawn push I could
take a nun takes okay the night would be
defended I could go back here and then
get my knight into the center but I kind
of want to be assured that I have some
Queen exchange at this point even if I
damage my structure
let's take here and now we're going to
offer a queen exchange if they don't
call for the Queen exchange then this
pond lives he's unprotected that's what
they're going for
on the rook
threatening a mate down here on h2 maybe
rook here have h2 covered
just give me a piece and time pressure
on the rook
in no time they resigned back determine
it's a big win had a time edge and
cause some mistakes there time pressure
less than 10 left less than 9 colic 32
with fire not too many I don't think
anybody else join this 186 is where it's
going to stay guessing
so let's see what we got a six-point
lead let's try and finish strong here no
more shoes is my opponent a dutch let's
try this
let's go see for
it's Castle first I might want to go
with b3 and Bishop e3 now let's try for
this I'll play Bishop f3
I want to force either some knight move
or some pawn move some concession I
would love to see this because then this
is a whole
let's go here
don't know if this is best but
can try this move I'm on e six
and can I not start chipping away at the
light square so we could take here
Bishop g4 and even insist on this move
especially after the Knight moves right
now I want to sink into the e6 square
and also cut off the communication
between Bishop and pawn he may fall
let's capture him with check and play
here right away scooping him up although
I'm not threatening that
I'm not threatening this because of rook
takes Bishop but now I can win that pond
capturing here first and then taking Ani
for my queen is enormous I just have to
be careful of this F file pressure oh I
think I want my queen out of the way and
then e five and then this although my
queen is pretty pretty good right where
she's out let's get some development in
connect my rooks they're going to triple
up I could always play off three maybe
shoot for this yeah maybe that's best
let's go for it
on the triple up I'm going to play off
three I don't want to do that we'll go
with f3 f3 it is
and hmm I feel like I want a queen
exchange let's try for it
and get this move in let's go with this
I'm covering this square so my queen
could rely upon h3 clean here ah and now
my queen is offsides mmm
okay I hate to have to defend like this
but oh now now I want my queen over here
I didn't see that that ID with the Queen
slipping in yep I have to be
very very careful there's some ideas of
capturing on f3 I should probably get
out of this pin I feel like I'm busted
somehow I might have to part ways with
my C pawn yeah so Queen takes they're
here Queen takes a rook takes c7 I want
to look up I think I can do that come
all the way back God defend my seventh
it's unfortunate but my queen or their
queen is really making coordination very
difficult for these three guys where's a
good home for this bishop I just want
them exchange it off play Bishop g5
they're really in the think tank great
to see that under 30 seconds they have a
connection issue now let's play here get
out of the Queensway and secure f3 a
little bit more my bishops unprotected
I'm expecting you that kind of a move
let's play Bishop here okay I'm finding
a way to organize I think at least I
have this square covered let's play back
here this allows rook here but I could
sneak in this way I didn't see I was
dropping that phone maybe that was
better
what's that Queen move about rook trade
yes happy to see the rook exchange makes
life a lot easier okay okay and they
resigned back determine a little bit
scary there that's for sure their queen
was on a rampage on the Queen side she
juked me she faked me out
I went Kings side she went Queen side
all right this is going to be the last
game it will most likely not count for
the tournament two minutes and change
should be getting one more pairing
though maybe not
it'll say up here if it's a let me
closed still says to get ready so let's
see what we get with a three oh maybe
you don't get another pairing if it
falls under two minutes on the 88
players it'll be closed let's see one
more pairing or not I think it was the
classical time control they would
already shut it down we're going to see
got a seven-point edge yep one more game
already
it's finished strong let's try g3
is Indian attack
it should have four with tempo at some
point let's try it now
hmm now if they do this I want night c3d
5 take out the night he's the key
defender of D 5 so here here here
maybe this stuff into D 5 is a welcome
sight now I get to pounce on the d5
square with an attack and let's go for a
night reposition they're allowing me to
key in on these weak squares B 6 and D 5
are both holes and soon to be occupied
with my Knights
if I go here they feels no he's going to
be trapped although no no not sure
Knight b6 pick up the light square
bishop
you
yeah I'll go for that it's the more
valuable bishop
let's take here and I don't need my
bishop on this diagonal anymore let's go
here I start to cut in at a lot of a lot
of squares in blacks position the queen
is almost paralyzed let's poke around
over here I just want to mix up start
some trouble
play this don't allow Knight d4 and I
controls this 97 I could take here let's
improve my queen and I can contest this
file rook to b5 takes I challenge the
knight have a passed pawn Knight here
takes I end up winning the h6 pawn I
don't want my knight to be challenged
okay so that's some getting some
activity there is that rook up to
well let's go with this one not even
allow rook 82 to hit this pawn they're
not in a position to combat the B file
this pawn controls the knight pretty
even on time
don't know why I hesitated there I
looked away for a moment and now I could
enter with the rook right here has to be
good they threatening 96 now let's go
here 96 maybe I have rook here and then
I avoid the knight exchange I want to
kind of circle in I want my bishop out
of the way let's start with this Queen
here
Knight here I want my Bishop to move and
then play h4 I could just win this pawn
what am I talking about now but then
they get the a pawn opposite colored
bishops what's that move about I'm able
to take this Knight
I'm winning a piece now
a perpetual x' No
I could defend with this and just defend
just defend my pawn but King g2 Queen
takes D there's Queen takes pawn here
okay now I'm going to do this play Queen
f3 discard some stuff first
threatening this and then Bishop to e6
may be expecting Queen c4 behind on time
Queen c4 needs to be played even on time
uhh
let's oh I could defend that pond well
that's good if I don't drop my pond I
got everything covered now even this
Bishop c6 into d5 yeah it's just a now
that's the Queen no time
that should do it yep they resign back
to tournament that's going to be it
36:29 25 final standings deejay chess
dog just out of podium land with 23 very
long username in at 22
88 players in all let's have a look at
all pages 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 & 9 that's going
to do it
ten games in 55 minute tournament to the
87 of you could games all
all righty
you
[Music]